the biggest issue that so many people
have is they talk about things in theory
versus reality if you just listen to
this company I'm doing this for everyone
here like what are you gonna do like you
just
you know which is amazing like you're
coming from a good place you'd like this
for them but like I just also don't
think you have an answer to the shortcut
so you have no other choice I think we
should go to the audience now uh so we
have a few microphones at the front of
the room give a question for Gary we're
gonna ask you to do is line up behind
one of these microphones and Gary will
choose you
based on who's in the lines I highly
recommend you get your ass in line let's
get going
my friend I'm well
four years ago I stood here in front of
you 2019
and you spoke to the whole room and said
if you're not on tick tock
you're killing yourself you're killing
your business
and that night I went home made my first
video and an 80 year old boy said to me
in the comments never do that [__] again
I exit for one year on Tick Tock and a
couple of years later
um I had half a million followers
I didn't always look like this
um so I created a mascotic character on
Tick Tock
um I'll listen to everything you said
and during that time I created a
business as well
um I've knocked every door I I who's
there listened to me I went to the
shelves to like stock my products I did
everything which you asked me to do took
the nose took the nose took the nose
didn't let me get down I got there in
the end but then also I realized that
you said to me in that 2000 meeting 2019
that people are trying to be 3-0 uh
there will be a lot of wrong decisions
you'll make and I did make a lot of
wrong decisions because my first product
didn't go very well but we are created
it I made the second product which I'm
selling since since um January 2000 this
year 2023
so
I just want to know
even though I I understand that there's
not gonna be three and zero it's always
going to be wrong decisions right
decisions when do you know that you give
up when do you know that it's not
working when when does the ambition and
ability become confused when do you know
that you go back to what you were good
at which is social media yeah
um and the second part of that question
is
if you think well sorry the second part
is like how do you position yourself in
the market well on the first one you
know by the results
if if you go for a long period of time
and people are not buying your product
your product is wrong
so this is the thing the product is
selling but when I'm selling it okay so
I've been to so many investors
um I've been on a couple of TV shows as
well which will be airing later this
year so I don't talk much about it the
investors have told me that the product
is not scalable because the product
price is quite High the product quality
is good I've since January 2023 I've
sold 10 000 units just doing farmers
markets over the weekends okay
so the product sells when I sell it when
people know what it is but on its own do
they do they do they issue do they
repeat buy from you yes absolutely so
haven't you actually won
yes but I want to have the mass the
scale why because that's what my dream
is why
um because I want to leave a legacy for
who or my child okay but why are you
defining that on math
um
probably because that's one of the
dreams I always had since being a child
that I want to build a company which
everybody should know about well then
you should adjust what you're doing
you're talking out of both sides of your
mouth
clear that it doesn't scale in its
current form right
you just said you want to do a mass but
you're telling me but it sells when I
sell it but that's inherently not
scalable so which is it
um I want to scale so I want to bring
down the costs so bring down the costs
okay
well this is the this is the thing I can
only bring down the cost by reducing the
quality of the product I understand but
you just told me the number one kpi is
scale
maybe it's nothing
see see that's the difference that's the
difference
um you know what I mean yes that's like
I'm gonna move on because we took a lot
of time on this that what I did for you
is why I did it that way and why I stuck
with it is I wanted everybody to hear
that you can't have both
if both can't coexist if he's talking I
want scale that's the most important
thing that's this Legacy well then you
can't have a subjective opinion on
quality
is a McDonald's burger quality
the bottom line is the person that's
eating it gets to decide not me not you
but they hit scale
scale is not debatable quality is
debatable
and last thing in 2019 I wanted to give
him a food product it was not ready but
now it is I'll take it brother
thank you
hi Gary thanks so much for your um
generosity or my daily podcast every
morning thank you what's your name
Fatima
um I set up a management consulting
company
um after being bullied in corporate okay
whilst suffering from a anxiety disorder
okay I've grown up to seven figures
organically predominantly through
Linkedin wow
um my question is because I'm in a male
dominated industry and I know you're not
a male but you probably work with
successful women how can I be disruptive
so that I can gain the attention of the
companies that are constantly bringing
in the mail Consulting companies you
know typical middle-aged white hair
um as opposed to people like me that are
female-led entrepreneurs you've already
succeeded though you're doing seven
figures
yes but I feel like I've sort of stalled
like there's so much more I've got plans
to do and want to do um and I'm just
kind of like not sure what the next step
is yeah I mean I think you're also very
young in your journey like
those old white males a lot of times
it's not because they're white males
it's because they've been doing it for
30 years and a lot of people buy
experience
like I mean if you've been able to scale
to seven figures you just gotta keep
doing it
you know what I mean you're not going to
convince anybody yeah
yes you're definitely not going to
convince them on the thesis of you why
are you picking these guys over me yes
that's not a compelling argument
you say not to try to convince people
but have conviction
I mean I just feel like a lot of time
what I'm worried about is you're making
an ideological
framework for yourself like I'm gonna
[__] show them like they're not you
know what I mean yes like even the way
you said white male older white male
means that you have disdain towards it
which I think is actually a
vulnerability
yeah good point you know what I mean
like there's um I know unlimited female
black Asian like there's there's people
win in all shapes and sizes of course
there's discrimination of course there's
bias of course there's ways to go on
getting Equity to where we want none of
that is stopping your business
so don't focus on that thing Bingo thank
you you got it
okay okay here okay what's your name
Erica Eric Erica but I live in Melbourne
um so I found you in 2017 when I was I
had my second baby I was breastfeeding I
had my electricity on the payment plan
was looking for coins to buy bread I
wasn't like America broke because I'm
from America yep but in Australia we
were broke yep and I kept you know
because y'all we have a good here come
on okay so I was listening I was
watching your YouTubes and I found
crushing it and I heard you kind of give
a loving [__] slap of like who cares
about your story no one's coming to find
you you got to get out there and build
it and I started I like quit my job and
my husband was freaking out he had no
money but I'm like [__] it like it's
here I gotta do this and I wouldn't be
here where I am if it wasn't for you uh
that first year of my business I did my
anchor podcast like [__] I don't know
what I was doing in my car my Hoops were
hitting the Apple [__] headphones the
e-tag was going off and beeping and [__]
because we'd have money and that podcast
has like 2.6 going down lows now because
of you so thank you you know
um it's wild
um
so I did all that and now we are where
we want to be and we're and we're we're
about impact and I want to help millions
of women and I hear you always say if
you want to help Millions [__] act
like it with how you show up your
content all that I got Nina my social
media ballerina over there shout out to
you it's two of us trying to do you know
the content and I [__] love it I
would do it underwater asleep [__]
talking in my sleep I love this [__] but
how do we I guess scale on socials and
not [__] I got two young kids and I
want to like watch them grow up of
course you like 24 7 and I love talking
to people in the DMS yep like how do we
do that with a very small team about
wanting to kind of be everywhere because
we want to reach maximum people by by
YouTube getting better at that by by
YouTube being better at the content okay
let me explain what I mean by that we
are living in the craziest era of social
since I've started talking about this in
2006. people in here could not even have
an account and tomorrow make a video
that gets more views than both of us
combined have ever gotten on the Merit
of the content the way you can get
bigger is by being better at the content
do you understand what to do in the
first three seconds of a tick tock do
you understand the titling do you
understand what time to be posting do
you like this is a craft
there's a there's there's a craft to
being better at the content so I think
you've got the personality that can get
you to a certain level yeah but if
you're asking me a direct question of
how do we get better you get better by
understanding moments of opportunity a
new platform pops out which is why four
years ago I was here saying tick tock
tick tock tick tock because I knew what
was happening there but then when it
gets mature and it's not that easy you
have to be better at the craft I don't
know how much time the two of you are
spending on re no no no I'm really
understanding how the algorithms work on
understanding why a carousel ad will do
this yeah how you know how much are you
posting on LinkedIn okay yep I'm posting
on LinkedIn right yeah so at what time
yeah how many words what quality over
like a [__] load of posts both because
we're not putting [__] out like it's not
[__] just to do it like we're trying to
put good [__] but it's a million
platforms now because you know sometimes
you're like post 50 times a day and it's
like I do have that with [__] so we have
one
but what is shipping decided on the
results or your subjective opinion of
you grading your own homework yeah yeah
like nobody thinks their kids ugly
the boys like that one let's go fellas
um yeah I I think I think the biggest
conversation that's not being had and
the reason I'm sticking on this one is I
know this will help all of you is are
you good at your craft yep you know like
do you understand what time to post how
long the copy should be what the fam
thumbnail Mr B spends 150 000 on a
thumbnail
Mr B spends a hundred fifty thousand
dollars per thumbnail on his YouTubes
that would make me and all of you
understand that a thumbnail matters most
people here have no idea what their
thumbnail is when they post whatever is
[__] defaulted
right so I would say for you too more on
the craft you're welcome thank you hi
guys my name is Nick hello I was part of
eruption five I was the addict who for
26 years and overcame that addiction two
and a half years clean now all right
thank you I am so I post my journey on
social media I feel I'm making an impact
I'm still trying to get a [__] handle
on life and it's a journey I'm learning
we all are yeah yeah and um like I'm
impacting people I'm starting to be
consistent in the gym and I'm getting
[__] messages I'm consistency too
this is amazing and and the thing is I'm
unemployed I'm just wondering do you
have any advice of how I can monetize
what I'm doing or I mean monetize you
know do you want to get a job
yeah but but that's this is me like I
love I love posting my journey but I'm
asking you a really practical question
because I want you to win
monetizing is very challenging let me
explain you've got to either get brand
deals
you've got to either be a big enough
Creator where you're getting meaningful
money from the revenue share of the
platforms which you have to be at a very
high level for that
you have to create a product to sell all
three of those are challenging you could
create a course or charge your audience
I think that changes the entire Dynamic
of it so I think you have to be
monetizing is challenging
the reason I'm asking is do you want to
get a job I think the same tenacity
you're attacking this with applying to
10 or 15 jobs a day
with good copy and good videos is
something you also have to give a
thought to yeah because I think the
stability of having the job nine to five
and then do content afterwards might
take the anxiety off because when you're
unemployed it's on your mind yeah 100
and then you may you might actually be
sitting on some it's very important I
want everybody to hear this you might be
sitting on something very powerful but
you have to keep doing it for another
three years before it goes to where you
want it to but if you're so anxious to
turn it into money you're going to lose
your audience because they're going to
feel it and all you needed to do was get
a nine to five oh my God
[__] get that okay yes I understand
[Applause]
oh brother I love oh I'm sorry sister I
see you go ahead I didn't realize about
the four I apologize go ahead my man
that's all right uh personally welcome
to Melbourne we appreciate you
um uh my name is Ryle I'm a CEO and
found uh CEO and founder of a public
company in the B2B space
um a couple questions firstly tomorrow
night my mum my wife makes a great
chicken soup do you want to come for
Shabbos yeah so that's an incredible
invite but I don't know if you know this
I'll be leaving at 4am on my way to
Sydney and then to Brisbane back and uh
in America on Sunday I'm uh I'm on a
[__] tour out here well we'll miss
you at Shore but next time next time uh
secondly look you put out a lot of
content recently around personal around
b2c yes we're in the B2B space What are
you seeing in the B2B space what's the
next play and I think it's really an
untapped Market I agree what do you
think how so I think LinkedIn and I've
mentioned it already twice think about
that I'm obsessed with LinkedIn for B2B
most of vaynermedia's growth right now
is in B2B clients because we are
annihilating LinkedIn because LinkedIn
is acting like Facebook 10 years ago
so to me LinkedIn for B2B is is a golden
era right now the media and the creative
opportunities both on organic region
creative but then targeting cios or
procurement like the ad targeting is
insane it's like the [__] that Facebook
got yelled out for that they still have
so LinkedIn by far starting podcasts
that are made for just a couple hundred
people back to when I was asking that
gentleman do you really need scale if
you're in B2B and you're only targeting
850 companies in all of Australia you
only need 850 listeners
and so a B2B podcast that you can do to
then shop up so you have creative to run
ads on LinkedIn is that what I'd be
thinking about what are you seeing from
a trend point of view as well product or
service what do you seeing over there in
the states which sort of coming across
your desk I just think the biggest trend
is how AI is going to disrupt a lot of
these products and services you know I
think from a product standpoint the
aiification of so many of these products
is like that Warfare has begun
um that's probably the biggest
observation by far
thank you thank you yes darling thank
you I'll be quick with this one uh my
name is Chris I am an ADHD leadership
coach oh I'm sorry she's going over
there you're nice
I work with uh leaders who have ADHD
autism dyslexia dyspraxia yes yeah yes
and you asked you start talking about
this idea of reverse engineering what
people find valuable yes and this is
something that I am particularly trying
to integrate into my life because I do
have a knack for putting myself out in
community building my ideas by bouncing
them off other people yes I need the
verbal process me too to do this me too
but then making sure that I'm pulling
out the right question to ask from all
that information that I'm learning and
then how do I answer that question in a
way that's going to be
um really powerful for an audience so
how do I reverse engineer that by doing
the Reps meaning by giving out all those
answers and all those hypotheses the
volume is the Breakthrough the reason
stuff is very clear to me
is because a lot of the work I do
is public and you don't see it meaning
go look at every post I've posted
analyze it
like you can see over a course of like
six months me get to the point
through little steps on a daily basis
like if you think about me being
consistent it's because it's small
variations of saying the same thing in
different context points until it hits
the crescendo this is the whole concept
of perfection that everyone's got
confused even the way you're thinking
about it right is like so powerful I
think this could really liberate You by
trying to get there over like notice how
you're like I need to do it verbalizing
and I was like me too the only
difference is I'm not trying to solve
the problem for a perfect answer one
time I'm doing it over and over through
the content
that is amazing and very helpful thank
you you're welcome yes darling go ahead
hi hi
I'm good
thank you
in 2019 I've been diagnosed with
multiple sclerosis and I have affected
eye moments and 40 disability but the
thing is
um
I still are happy I've done over a
million dollar business in last five
years and
[Applause]
my complicators are my haters they hate
me and
you do understand
you just said your competitors are your
haters they hate you right
yes you do understand the number one
goal every business has
is for their competitors to hate them
that is a tremendous accomplishment
my mother 's earlier uh we a male
dominating market and I think I have
done good being a woman but now I'm
angry because I have more than enough
savings and I'm entering into B2B uh
business I will be probably opening my
own RTO by this year now I'll be the
sole director and CEO of that business
and now those uh who are right now
hating me I'll be into the business then
those will be my perspective
now the thing is
how to I don't tell everyone that I have
MS I don't want to take pity uh you know
yep
um I I want to uh just be positive yeah
um about that they should take a
positive uh like this like I I I'll be
able to do the business how should I
create a positive impact on them well I
think first of all are you going to
still be in the prior business or are
you no so my husband he also helping me
big time he's there
um so
um he will be in the prior business and
I will be in another business now so
they're gonna hate him
it's just that because my eye moments
are not good enough and my hearing uh
problem is there and because I promise
obviously I yawn a lot and
but I have wings I want to fly
um as much as I can do I am doing it I
am not a woman who can say title I'm
just cook and clean I I just want to do
a lot of things in myself I'll be honest
with you like
if you if your next thing would was
going to be would you invest in my
business the answer would be yes like
you're so clearly motivated and capable
like I'm almost embarrassed to answer
your question because I don't think it's
going to have any level of impact I
think you're gonna will your way to
success in your next business
I mean it like these prospective clients
are either going to say yes or no my
intuition is if they all say no you're
going to take that feedback and come up
with another thing that people are going
to say yes to
okay right like that's what you do
you persevered through all of what
you've persevered through like you're
just capable of navigating it how do I
you know how when you say how am I going
to make it positive or how do I make it
positive you've already decided that
and the fact that you're not going to be
in that other business is probably going
to be a benefit some of those people are
going to be smart enough to do business
with you just to try to learn from what
you did in the last business which is
their business
yeah my last business I I just been
following you and each and every video I
see on Snapchat on tick tock on Insta
everywhere I follow you on Twitter as
well
um though very
um the thing which has helped me a lot
was like the one video of yours when you
said
um
you don't need big cameras you don't
need anything this Smartphone is more
than enough that that like I I really
love I I really got motivated enough and
I am here because of you this is what I
can say thank you thank you
Larry how are you I'm well my friend
a message on what's uh on Instagram I'm
excited to see you it'll be glad if you
can please reply me if you got it all
right uh so what I want to ask you see
um I'm huge in women Obama uh I've been
a chef for 22 years and because of my
wife I quit the job and I actually did a
full-time business from zero to six
figure in six months amazing and I come
from a family of doctors my father's a
spine surgeon my mom's a Physio and
while it was uh premium clients you know
the main thing which really really sort
of got me curiosity what he said and I
want to ask you for value
clients were coming to me and they were
having pain and they were going and I
was so curious about it why are they
having this pain
and then as I look at the competition
so what I really found out I actually
according to the same same Bowl I during
covert actually injured my shoulder I
injured my back and I spoke to my dad he
couldn't really help me I spoke to my
mom she couldn't really help me so I
went to the physios I went to the osteos
and they gave me some Correctional
exercise which did help but the main
thing that's happened I lost my
motivation of exercising again so I
started finding a gap and the Gap would
have really realized that the main thing
what people really come into the fitness
is because they lack posture
and because of kosher when you're
sitting down to doing any exercise no
matter you go to the world best shape if
people won't really fix your posture
they'll show that you're gonna get
injured so what my the Gap I found is I
started digging deep in started hiding
the best coaches around the world and it
came with a plan that I want to look
after especially women because they're
hard-working women and they all support
their family
to fix their posture before giving them
a dream come true or give you six pack
yeah
so what I really want to ask that when
people come to me first of all they want
to see the senior which is physios uh
all other places
and I'm giving them a lot of value right
they let them dictate their life
and someday they come and question me
and I sometimes really really feel bad
in my Integrity I probably saw so many
things and sometimes I think I'm not
able to add that value of all the
patient hard work and actually working
with the Curiosity going through
depression anxiety during covert to get
that piece of product which is meant for
Vitality meant for being happy not going
to the doctors I got it having a laundry
life so I just wanted to help me how can
I get that value added to my business so
that people really think they take
everything for granted oh you fix my leg
oh that's said I'm gonna start walking
so I'm like what if five years or ten
years later you are actually not able to
walk
they don't really think about it so I
really want to sort of I found a gap and
this is for mental health
and I have people I've got this new way
of exercising away but what's the Gap
that you're trying to fill for yourself
in this scenario you feel
underappreciated or under compensated no
I'm actually trying to get that
compassion what I see in people a vision
where five years at 10 years down the
lane if they want to come to me and they
were still going through the process
like as a fitness coach I want to bring
that together yes I understand but why
because I love doing that but okay so if
you love doing it you don't need the
feedback loop for what you're asking for
no I just want to say how can you add
value how can you make people you've
you've added value but sometimes people
don't take it that way that's because
you're looking for that validation
okay no that's true but how can I
overcome the valuation and how can I
break that process by by recognizing
that a lot of times
getting that validation comes later
it's all right you've been doing it for
six months oh no no training I've been
doing it for 17 years yes my business
started when I was actually left the job
building code and six months I actually
grew up my business yep and I was
working so the business going on for 17
years got it but full time I've been
understood look I think I think what's
very clear is and I get it is
I just think that the the the
validation that you're seeking
is just not it's going to be as
transactional as you'd like it to be all
right so I'll tell you one I want to ask
one okay can I ask one question please
real quick please real quick so when you
said about the parents yes like because
they mean doctors yes and I came as a
chef yes there was a huge intimidation
of course you can't be a doctor of
course please come to my father and say
of course that you you're such a big
doctor yes right so how can I fix that
if you think that's a validation just
give me one answer thank you why would
you care about that let's talk about it
so your Dad's friend your uncle whoever
it is
to your point I believe what you were
saying I was going to end with that
knowing the history of doctors with a
chef you know when you were doing it
that was like the help you know a chef
right I think that insecurity feeling is
what's happening to you with your need
for validation from the patients you're
trying to prove something I get it like
because that's a lot of judgment thrown
at you coming up in your life of course
I think you got to let it go
it doesn't mean anything as if someone's
opinion of you matters I don't want to
let a girl but still it just seeps
inside me I don't know why it seeps
inside of you because you were dominated
by it you were pounded by it from your
heritage that doctor Dr Chef you just
you that was a lot that was a lot to be
thrown at you but you've got to release
that you've got to release it
you got it
hey Gary well hey Gary
um my core mission is to harness the
cognitive potential of humanity my name
is Justin I'm an AI coach and I help
CEOs and executive leaders Elevate to
their cognitive potential by using AI
one of the joys I have at the moment is
working with the leadership team of a
school okay you mentioned some comments
about you know School marks and and
clearly not reflective of smarts
the schools that we went through were
designed in one way like if you got to
redesign a school today that was more
suitable to you with everything you know
about AI with everything you know about
what you need students coming in
like what are you putting in a school of
the future that you're building you know
for me if I'm thinking about creating a
curriculum the concept of information
memorization is ludicrous
asking kids to memorize stuff for tests
is silly when we have technology where
it is today for me I would try to build
a school that was building self-esteem
and was teaching kids how to interact
and was teaching kids practical things
like real rules of society like
competition and Merit how to pay your
taxes like what life insurance means it
would be completely based on common
sense and kindness
of course like when people like know
Gary you don't get it you have to teach
core skills I'm like do you know any
people are homeschooled and learned at
home like you can t like core skills are
pick up on a ball like they're there
they're always there like yeah okay
you'll teach math but like I just think
that we don't think about positioning
people for real life that's all Academia
for the sake of Academia yeah we had
this cool opportunity to personalize the
learning right so like is there a class
is there a something you'd love to go
back and do differently all of it I
[__] hated school
you know like like the fact that I
wasn't taught like about marketing or or
like you know proper investing or just
normal [__] like it's just it's crazy we
teach no life skills
and and to the parents that are worried
about privacy of AI data do you think
that's a thing that we're just going to
shift our mindset around that every
single person in this room's privacy and
data has been compromised already yeah
it has let's listen nobody wants their
date data or privacy compromise but it's
already happened like every government's
been hacked every organization all your
banks have been had like it's all there
I know what you're doing tonight
yeah
thank you thank you
hi hi
um my name is forsha and this is my mom
Rebecca and I was wondering how I could
convince my mom to let me have some
social media platforms
so I could so I could like show my
dancing and acting and stuff
well I think look look I think that's a
decision between you and your mom I that
I have no interest in getting involved
in
but I would say to your mom there is a
way to it's like look this is a
philosophical thing for parents forever
we for a lot of us in this room that our
parents now what's going on with social
media reminds me so much around alcohol
right so alcohol in America we banned
alcohol in the 30s and 40s just like
some people ask us to ban social media
today what it did was it created a
byproduct of even worse Behavior people
were still doing it anyway and our
relationship with alcohol has never been
great in our country for that reason
a lot of parents here know because we
went to University and college with kids
that parents were very very strict and
made everything demonized and the first
week of college they got blackout drunk
every night because they didn't know how
to balance it so I think today social
media has that stigma for parents and I
think for a lot of parents there is ways
to do it in a way that can be a little
bit of moderation at a time sometimes
you can start with only the family
members are able to follow the kid and
things of that nature so I think you and
your mom have to have a second level
conversation you got to convince her mom
it's not all or nothing it's not like I
want to go on Tick Tock and go crazy and
you can't watch maybe you can make it a
private account and maybe only you mom
can decide who gets to follow me and get
to see my stuff and maybe you start
going a little bit one step at a time I
think too many kids and parents have the
All or Nothing approach without having
maybe a slow and steady approach
thank you
um hi Gary hi Rebecca I've been
following you for a very long time I
work in the mental health space just
recently and specialize in children uh
teenagers mainly yes and Porsche is 12
turning 13. yes and so many kids that
I've seen already have got huge
addictions to gaming yeah
um social media online you know watching
gaming and their parents want me to help
them with their mental health yeah but
they're spending four or five hours a
day online
so that's why for me it's really
difficult for me I get it I get it to
say here you go here's Tick Tock when I
know what the algorithms do for you know
the undeveloped brain yeah but just to
just to put it into a different
perspective when I was you know 14 a
little bit older you know everybody was
mad at models and magazines because they
were so skinny and all the girls in my
high school were in the bathroom
throwing up because they all thought
they had to be Kate Moss
because we looked at magazines when I
was in high school everyone was talking
about people playing Nintendo for four
hours a day or what or the TV was the
problem humans are always going to be
addicted to something
yeah because you know like I think I
think and by the way you know this for
every kid that you see and what you do
for a living there's another kid who is
handling it
you know and so I think parents just
love their kids so much that they this
generation of parents you and I included
is driven by fear at a level that we
have not seen in parenting in a very
long time
and and that fear is making us do things
that are very different all of us that
are in our 40s and above also had
another thing our parents want weren't
up our [__] ass every minute like we
are with our kids
a lot less claps for that one
so I think we've got a double issue at
hand we have the most fear-based
parenting generation of all time
and we have parents that are in our kids
business at a level that is unheard of
so we've become micromanaging fear-based
mongers and our children are actually
having counter effects to this we think
we're doing good we're so up their ass
they don't know how to be grown-ups by
the time they're talking I'm not
grilling you I'm not killing you I'm
gonna get home she's gonna be like I
told you you know look I think the
scariest thing on Earth is to tell
anyone how to parent their child I think
it's completely out of bounds I will say
that this has been going on for a while
I also have the luxury of interacting
with an ungodly amount of people and a
lot of them are now 18 20 and 22 and
many hundreds of them work for me and
many more ten thousands of them talk to
me and I can tell you that we've got to
let these kids breathe a little bit
just a little bit we are so far up their
ass
most of us are strong
because we were out in the jungle a
little bit what we're doing in modern
parenting is we're creating zoo animals
we're putting them in these cages and
we're trying to take care of them and I
don't know if you know what happens to
an animal that grew up in the zoo when
they put them in the wild they die
within a minute
because they go out to the real jungle
and the lion tears their [__] head
off
and so what I think is happening is that
we are micromanaging and zoo animal
mingling our kids so much out of fear
because we love them so much and we know
what they're doing every [__] second
that we're actually not preparing them
for life and I think like the old saying
in Russian that is my favorite Russian
saying it translates to everything is at
its best when there is balance
and I think we've lost our Collective
balance
[Applause]
hey Gary
um my name is Samson and uh
um it's good to see you you changed my
life so thank you um seven years ago I
uh it's the first time I know about your
content
and then I'll say one of those kids
who's always been learning and never you
know doing anything and then I was in a
very
um
I was in a job kind of suffering a lot
and then
um so five years ago I read crush it and
then that kind of demonstrated to me
um how like people who have who are
successful or have a little bit of
success needed you know how much work
you needed to get there it kind of you
know gave me that Awakening and then I I
quit my job and then I find something
that actually maps to
um where I wanted to go yes and um two
years ago I get into a digital marketing
agency a mid-size of
um advertising agency in Australia and
I'm very happy
um from there and um I'm loving it I'm
not selling my crafts every day so I
just really want to say um thank you
thank you um yeah
um
for me
I know um because I love you so much in
the future in the future not right now
um I really want to kind of work for you
or have been here so email me at
because we're hot we're exploding in
Australia and so we're hiring
I was gonna ask what kind of tips You're
Gonna Give You know people around like
you just gave me like it's direct it's
okay
what'd I do
hi Gary hello hi hi Gary hi it's um such
you're such an inspiration to me I've
been following you um for so many years
as well
um I was cautious age when I arrived on
a boat um as a refugee from northern
Iraq um the Kyrgyzstan region if you if
you know of course
um and then um obviously as a person
from that sort of background I've been
through a lot but I never made an excuse
to uh give up on my dreams and so on and
so forth as everyone else is so
inspiring here but um honestly I started
reading on self-development
um a long long time ago when I couldn't
even speak English properly
um but um I think the most
convincing person and also after having
read your book especially the chapter
about conviction
um it really made me it was like a punch
in the face it's I I quit law actually
two years ago when I was pregnant with
my second child there are there were a
few pregnant people while they were
listening to you I thought she was
telling my story honestly like
um the beautiful lady in the pink from
America
um so when I was pregnant I was um I
don't know if anyone knows lendlies
maybe I shouldn't give out my previous
employment history but I was working for
them not as a lawyer but as an admin
assistant to make my life easier while I
was pregnant so that I don't have as
much stress as a lawyer yes
strategically I remember walking along
the uh I don't even know the name of the
roof but in the city
um I was listening to your podcast every
single day while I had a different
mindset at work and then outside I was
pumped every single day walking to
exercise to make my child healthy and
then I said you know what effort I'm
gonna quit I will not go back to law I
will never go back to Business
Development management and so on and
then I started creating nfts which I had
absolutely or no idea about it so I
started creating nfds and I only sold
two but that's not the point two is
better than zero exactly and then I
started making uh reconnecting with my
childhood love of drawing
um but of course to the disappointment
of my parents my mom was like oh my
daughter does these days is draw and she
went from law and human rights lawyer
and all the education you can imagine
you know when you become a lawyer and
then I did a master of international
relations and then I'm doing absolutely
nothing with it other than that it's um
just you know a stepping stone and maybe
use it as a strategy that I've that I
have those things on my resume but isn't
that interesting
um that I sorry I'm fascinating myself I
guess
sorry I don't know how where that came
from but
um
what I'm trying to say is um I
disappointed my parents and um and I'm
obviously not proud of that but I for
the first yes
the number one thing
that most people on Earth should be
doing is disappointing their parents did
you hear that and I I mean this here's
why yes
deep down especially immigrant parents
like we all we all know the story
deep down
push comes to shove maybe not to your
face
but as a parent yourself
the number one thing a parent wants is
their child to be happy yes
[Applause]
it is very obvious how parents get into
this trap because we've lived through
just like maybe our generation is
micromanaging too much
our parents generation and their parents
generation valued the neighbor's opinion
too much yes
most parents of the last two generations
push their children to do things
literally based on other people's
opinions not even their own opinion
about their own child 100
you should have disappointed your
parents I should have done it way
earlier that is disappointing
um I bet you know now that I'm 35 and
you know it's funny because when you
have kids and I've had this from a lot
of people
um once you have kids and it was so
funny hearing it from me when you said
your father was only paying you 70k a
year and then you realize much later
like oh gosh like what he's not paying
me at all so I should speak up
um so it's sometimes it requires uh some
time of course and you know like of
course all done but then one day you're
like okay that's it that's right I'm
gonna follow my own that's right path
because I've you know time and by the
way a lot of people get upset with me
they're like Gary why are you saying
this and I say to the parents I'm trying
to save you
I'm like the quicker your kid
disappoints you the more likely you'll
have a long-term relationship with your
kid
what people don't realize is people that
Lit kids that live their lives for their
parents start to build resentment for
their parents as every day goes by and
the longer they continue to live their
lives for their parents the more likely
they're going to have a poor
relationship with their parents
and it's evident evidenced by the
relationship I'm having with my parents
um unfortunately because they're not
understanding the path I'm taking which
is now I'm about to go live with my
product I'm not here commercializing
that but I'm just so proud of myself
despite the backlash and the um you know
the the sort of you know the whatever um
they've given me I basically feel like
I'm on my own On My Own Worst even
though the supporters can I get can I
give you good news they're going to get
over it yeah I reckon I have a really
good idea yes go to a store that does
custom shirts yes and I want you to make
a shirt for your parents that says draw
Over Law
and I want you to give it to them
yes right to their [__] face
absolutely yes
I thank you from the boys I wish you
better than your heart desires thank you
thank you
we'll go over a little bit
hey Gary you're next hi hey brother um
so I can't hold you yes I know who you
are how you doing man
um yeah it rapidly it's the third
continent we've seen each other on this
year pretty cool yeah very very pleased
very fortunate
um so uh
last time we spoke in VidCon
um I mentioned the Tokyo dads podcast
that I'm working on yep still is driving
towards episode 55 to throw my standard
bike I was scared you're already there
and there was going to be time oh yeah
um so today I want to dive into
parenting okay a little bit sort of one
thing and you've mentioned many times
specific instances that your parents
have done certain actions yes I have you
know remember like your dad's handshake
yeah I'm pleasing you when you yeah
now what are some things that you do
specifically
um in practice with your children to
install these things I I do very similar
things so what he's referring to for the
people that really deep in my contact
talk about these singular moments where
I got positive reinforcement uh my mom
oh
the thing I think a lot about with
parenting is like if you tell your kids
it's all about Straight A's they get
formed into like believing and listening
to the system and they just become
workers or listen blindly or if you over
praise your children their whole lives
for being beautiful they become insecure
as they get older because their
validation sits in their looks or their
athletic ability or their school so I
think a big thing for all leaders here
whether for parents or your employees is
what are you praising and validating and
so for me I follow a very similar
blueprint you know with my with my son
he's got a lot of empathy he's got a lot
of feelings towards his friends you know
um I think about this one game he had in
baseball where he hit a line drive and
it hit the coach in the chest he [__]
nailed it was a great hit hit the book
and instead of running to the base he
stopped and went and checked on the
coach
and I continue to bring that up to him
literally every other week that he had
more compassion to see if the coach was
good than his own selfish needs or
excitement to succeed in the sport he
was playing with my with my daughter I
think about things about like when I see
that she's not putting too much pressure
on herself you're basically watching and
you're thinking about what validation
systems you can do on things that are
going to benefit them based on their
personalities
um back to the reverse engineering we
talked about earlier so you know look I
think
I think if you love yourself and you're
good to other people your life will
always be good there's unlimited people
on Earth who are deeply happy making
forty six thousand dollars a year in
annual income they exist at scale
and so I think we put so much time and
effort into so many other things and you
know for me I'm spending all my time
trying to make sure that they're just
happy
actually and it starts with you know
reinforcing
nice behavior either for others think
about the first story I told you or to
oneself
think about the Second Story
last one or two questions
hello Gary Hey Brother
um so my name is Mark um I'm 22 years
old firstly I am vlogging this so can
you say hi to my Vlog because they told
me I wouldn't be able to say hi to you
Vlog what's good
thank you Gary and thank you for
tweeting back at the Best Day Of My Life
um so I've been watching your content
for a while and I love everything you
talk about patience gratitude and
execution and I live by it I'm 22 and I
taste test everything and I lead into
curiosity my problem is with patience
and it's not because I want a million
dollars and it's not because I want to
make it it's because
um this Monday I'm going to be
re-watching my dad's business okay I
found I love social media whether it's
like advertising or being an influencer
or things like that and I'm relaunching
my dad's business and I'm happy to be
patient and do it patiently but um like
I don't understand how to be patient
with my family healthy deteriorating
sure right like I have a deep love for
my parents I didn't give a [__] how much
money I make I really want to make it
for my parents I I really don't care
like we've been renting for so long all
I want to do is make it for them I don't
care about the money for myself how do I
lead into patience this is a very
brother this is a very common question
because I talk about patients a lot
and this framework I get a lot of
questions about like Gary that's fine
and dandy but my mom is terminally ill
and she's going to be gone in less than
two years for sure and you can't tell me
patience I have to make it before she
goes and I say to that person this is
incredibly challenging I'm so sorry this
is the worst [__] I'm devastated but you
being impatient and taking shortcuts is
not going to create the thing you want
anyway
okay I'm giving you the answer to the
following as their health deteriorates
so what do you like talk it through
logically for me building anything
meaningful takes time yeah
so what are you going to do differently
like like what's gonna happen do you
think there's a shortcut you think I'm
going to tell you some trick you think
I'm going to give you a tidbit that like
it's just not how it [__] works it's
just like you know I I like I know you
talk about you know you gave up your 20s
to like live out your dreams and stuff
like that I've done I've done the same
no you haven't
no you haven't you haven't
not so low right like what but you
didn't give up you just said I've given
up my 20s or 22 you haven't started
lean inside that's good I lead into
doing things that I enjoy rather than
like going for things that have instant
gratification what you just said you
lean into things that you enjoy like
that make me happy well then you didn't
give up [__]
sounds like sounds like you're being
selfish you're giving up going out
things like that but you don't like that
anyway you like this more so what the
[__] did you give up I guess
okay so thank you
thank you but but this but I want to
help you here this is why we're doing
this
you didn't give it up yeah so keep going
yeah so I guess just for me like I watch
your content and I actually act on it
okay patience gratitude execution all
the time how do we overcome this issue
of patience when there's like you know
things that just can't be changed do you
recommend taking shortcuts do you
recommend taking a faster route like
you watch my content and think I'm gonna
tell you to take a shortcut
big question I have what what's the
shortcut talk this through because it's
very
very like shortcut like what what do you
what's the business
yeah he's a show he's a chauffeur
business okay so what shortcut are you
gonna take to make this show for a
business 10 times bigger to make it
before their health deteriorates
clickbait stuff
what's that clickbait style so do that
yeah yeah I guess what's clickbait stuff
I don't know like um
I don't know like I think Shady
marketing strats you know that like what
I can't think of them on the spot
because I try to be genuine when I
Market but like what what do you think's
gonna happen what's Shady you're not
doing a [__] click funnel and a
mastermind
sure so what's Shady what are you gonna
like trick someone to take the [__]
cap
like what Are You Gonna Knock on
people's door and throw them in the car
and drive and then tell them they owe
you 30 bucks the [__] are you good about
wait like I I what why I'm doing this
with you is you're talking philosophy
the biggest issue that so many people
have is they talk about things in theory
versus reality
if you just listen to this conference
I'm doing this for everyone here like
what are you gonna do like you just
we're gonna try my best yeah but like
you know which is amazing like I look I
you're coming from a good place you'd
like this for them but like I just also
don't think you have an answer to the
shortcut right so you have no other
choice yeah so what are you gonna do
when you start for your dad's business
what's the plan
um well he's had it for a while honestly
I love these guys but um it hasn't been
profitable for a while yep so I'm
re-watching it
um you know I'm going to be doing the
advertising for I'm going to try manage
these finances and I really want to just
like from his business you know like
just by stopping just by cutting costs
yeah and making it not not profitable
yeah you've already advanced it
dramatically that's right yeah that's
not a shortcut yeah that's working a p l
properly
thank you Gary you're welcome and um
you said if you don't ask you'll never
know so would I ever be able to get you
on my podcast which is about finding
gratitude and happiness
you know one thing that I said up there
is I'm working more on my Candor and so
listen I'm working on it too like no
[__] years ago 10 years ago I would
sit here and be like yes and everybody
would clap and then like there'd be an
80 chance I wouldn't do it right and I
don't want to be that person the answer
is maybe okay if you email me
and in the title put I was the kid that
was looking for the shortcut
you know maybe we'll sneak it in the
clickbait thumbnail anyway
I love you back
ladies and gentlemen diamonds
thank you
foreign
[Music]